here's one of the unfortunate things
that happens when you earn this amount
of money in a year right the government
says you want to earn that much money
we're going to take a cut by the way why
do they do that like what's it called
max okay why do they tax you good so
anything that you and I get to use for
free right the government has to pay for
somehow so things like say school roads
all those types of things you don't pay
for like you know oh I had to drive so I
paid fuel but I didn't pay for the road
okay so that has to come from tax so how
do you work out how much tax you're
going to pan right so this is scale and
for convenience I have loaded it up if
you've got the internet you can go ahead
you can look for 2014 tax rates the
reason you should look for 2014 is
because if i scroll down you'll see
every year every year they modify the
tax rates just a little bit okay so I've
got here we go there 2014-2015 tax rates
right here ok now let's just have a look
at this one scenario okay we earned in
this year just a bit over 30k okay so if
we're only thirty thousand dollar thirty
thousand twenty eight dollars and eighty
cents which of these tax brackets do I
fit in a good this one here okay so if
you're earning under eighteen thousand
two hundred you don't have to pay any
tax but as soon as you're earning a
dollar over that you're in this bracket
okay you've looked at tax brackets
before right so let me just write this
piece of information down because it's
gonna be important for us if wearing
here right from 18,000 201 dollars to
37,000 okay if that income lies between
here which it does at the moment how
much tax do we have to pay and says 19
cents for each dollar over
nineteen cents okay for each one dollar
over 18,000 200 okay so we're going to
take this idea and we're going to
translate I've written it here so that
now we can cross over actually I can
work this out so how are we gonna do
this oh I'm going to suggest we do this
piece by piece okay so first I want to
work out this part right how many
dollars have we earned over 18,000 200
okay good so there's some subtraction
happening right now you could get your
calculator out and do this reflection
but come on we've got this in a
spreadsheet right so if I say it fed tax
payable income over 18,000 oops sorry
eighteen thousand two hundred okay
instead of using a calculator do this
this thing is a calculator right so I
should take equals what
how much is over this amount right well
you're going to start with this that's
how much you're actually earning and two
I get how much more than eighty thousand
two hundred this year's I should
subtract right pretty sure I heard
before I ok so subtraction eighteen
thousand two hundred Bambi go so that's
how many dollars are going to have this
rule applied to them right the first
eighteen thousand two hundred dollars
tax free ok but then we've heard an
extra eleven thousand and four twenty
thousand eighty cents above that so
that's going to get taxed so therefore
our tax payable is going to be right
nineteen cents out of every one of those
dollars how am I going to calculate that
hmm there is giving a multiplication for
every one of these dollars i'm going to
multiply by now every time i get one of
those dollars they're going to take out
nineteen cents right so nineteen cents
out of every dollar nineteen cents out
of how many cents endure 100 sense so
that'sthat's the nineteen percent right
get it % okay so therefore as a decimal
because this thing is better than
writing doesn't work on this will be
zero point one nine that's nineteen
percent as a decimal makes sense so i'm
going to multiply by zero point 1 month
so that's how much you're actually going
to have to pay the government for that
amount of income that your home okay so
how much is left not much is that does
anyone know what it's called after
taking tax out and you get left with an
amount after that so it's it's if you've
ever seen on like packaging right
they'll say now here's a can of peaches
okay and it's 850 grams net weight okay
so this is a net income right it's not
including the tax that's been taken out
okay
so how do I work out what's left yeah
again subtraction here's how much you
earned and then they're going to take
their cut that's how much tax you have
to remove right total income minus the
tax that's payable here that time that's
what's left okay what's the opposite of
net income you know what's the opposite
when you have the whole thing start to
the G Bruce it's gross right so actually
a better name the total income would be
gross income it is gross okay they go
done